yeah all right and as you prefer prepare
lord for spring break can you also
prepare for st
patrick's day chef jeff of smith's is
preparing some appetizers perfect for
the occasion
check it out hello everybody i'm chef
jeff from smith's st
patrick's day is coming right up and
i've got a couple of recipes for you two
little fun appetizers that your family
is going to love
for whatever small get together you
decide to have or just by yourself
super good super easy let's get right
into it we're going to be making little
irish potato bites they're like little
twice baked potatoes they're so good and
then we're gonna make of course a lovely
green fruit salad
let's get right to it okay so irish and
potatoes and
that whole holiday and everything just
goes together really well and so we're
going to use
our little mini yukon gold potatoes for
this recipe you could use the little red
ones as well
work perfectly fine so i boiled these
for about 25 minutes just until they're
fork tender
and once you do that i'm gonna just go
ahead and cut those in half and then i
have a little scoop
that i'm just going to scoop out here
and as you can see i've got a lot of
them done already
usually this will make about 40 little
bites i think the recipe calls for 20
potatoes so
really easy and enough to feed a crowd
okay so we scooped out the inside don't
go all the way down because we need a
base for our
our potatoes to stick to okay so once i
get that in there
i'm gonna throw in some butter i'm gonna
throw in some sharp cheddar cheese
and then some corned beef now of course
corned beef i just go ahead and get this
from the deli at your local smiths
they have corn sliced corned beef you
can get there or you can just make your
own corned beef if you want to go
through that process
maybe you have some left over that's a
good way to use it up once you get it in
there let's get some salt and pepper in
there
just go ahead and mash it together like
so
and it will just all come together
nicely we're gonna end up throwing this
back in the oven so don't worry if the
cheese doesn't melt or the butter
doesn't completely get into it
once we get to that point then all we're
going to do is
take that mixture and put right back
into our little potatoes
just like so and then i've got some in
the oven my oven's 400 degrees let's see
how we
we did check it out
and they look fantastic and they're done
they're melty and they look so good
okay so we're gonna go on to our fruit
salad
lucky for us it's super quick so all i
have is some honeydew melon here
i've got some green pears i've got some
grapes kiwi green apple
we're gonna squeeze some lime juice onto
it
with our squeezer here we're gonna put
some orange juice
and then honey as well if i can get the
honey to come out
um get my spoon
all right just give that a stir and then
that is done
okay so let's finish up our our st
patrick's day little appetizer feast
here we'll get our salad here
maybe if you had some mint would be a
good idea to put on top of here
and we'll put a couple of our little
spuds on there
we're gonna go ahead and garnish them
with some sour cream like so
of course you can find all of these
ingredients at your local smiths
thank you so much for shopping thank you
so much for watching enjoy your st
patrick's day and we will see you next
time bye-bye
always looks so good smith's food and
drug has several locations across the
valley
smithfood and drug.com you can find out
more information there las vegas now